-I'm here with Alex Rodriguez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're about to go
head to head --
or face to face --
in a game of "Face Breakers."
We're going to take turns
hitting balls
at that wall of glass
with our faces on it.
That's my face.
That's Alex's face.
First person to break all of
their opponent's faces wins.
-Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
-That face, not my face, yeah.
All right, we're both
gonna be using
Alex's new bat right here,
the A-Rod GS25.
They're coming out in July.
Alex, you're up first.
Let's break some face.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Hmm.
-Maybe you should use the tee.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience ohs ]
I may need a tee.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Too high.
[ Audience ohs ]
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-You almost hit that too hard
right there.
Let me try one more.
♪♪♪♪
-Yeah!
-I'm feeling it now.
Let's go.
All right, first one to two.
Next one wins.
-All right. Yeah.
-Now I'm --
[ Audience ohs ]
♪♪♪♪
-Ooh!
Oh!
-You can't hit one of The Roots,
either.
♪♪♪♪
[ Audience cheers ]
-Oh!
-Can't do it right there.
-It's the bat.
-It's the bat. No, no.
The bat works.
I broke my own face.
The champ right there,
Alex Rodriguez, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I broke my own face.
We got these two bats.
You want to do something
with them?
-Any fans --
Any Yankee fans out there?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, we got two right there.
-Yeah.
Want to give them to them?
♪♪♪♪
-You get...
-Can you sign 'em?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go.
All right.
You got 'em.
-Come on.
Alex Rodriguez, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jamie Parker joins us
after the break.
Stick around!
-Oh, my God!
♪♪♪♪